With a bank account balance, the total makes perfect sense. The balance can be
added to when you deposit money, and it gets smaller when you withdraw money.
It's just a number that gets incremented and decremented in times. With friends
in a social network, I probably wouldn't be using this pattern. Because in a
social network, you don't just con, collect the number of friends that someone
has, you want to collect the actual friends. And that would not be a variable
that gets incremented or decremented. A car odometer? That again makes sense.
As miles accumulate, this not total just gets bigger. Notice that this one here
doesn't get smaller. that's fine. And finally, what were flag stripes. I don't
know, it's, a flag has a constant number of stripes, they don't change. So,
even though you may want to count the stripes, it's not the total pattern where
you have a quantity that has some method that adds to it. And maybe some method
that subtracts from it. The point is that, once you've seen a couple of classes
that keep a total of gas consumed, of miles driven, of money in the bank,
whatever. Then you start recognizing that particular pattern, and it becomes
easy for you to put in a method that adds something to the total that takes
something away. So, let's look at a few other patterns that you haven't seen so
much, but they are very useful in practice.